in game number 56 of the season for the
mavericks luca doncic with a 28 point
first quarter surpassing the 25 that
steph curry had in the game against
these los angeles clippers in the first
week of the season kelly ubrey and fred
van bleetz
what do you do when you score 30 points
you have 30 points
before the dog on half time
that's not normal though that is
the most you ever have that
back of the bubble still gives me
nightmares man
that was not fun
but then luca has put
zbots in the blender more than once when
you think about past matchups
watch with a score inside and left alone
for way too long luca finally decides to
take the three and nails it
all right i'm not sure what
two got hung up three team fouls on the
clippers in the first quarter
lucy gave it up got it right back into
the shot clock bye bye to zumax and the
giant killer
got played off the floor in these switch
situations and they couldn't play him a
whole lot actually
to those guys that are in the lineup
right now i think all of it is set up by
this guy right here
[Music]
this guy right here is doing some damage
he is putting the hurt on the clippers
early in the first quarter of the game
tonight with three made threes
which has been his mo and first quarters
actually
and another big one tonight
eight straight game where he's just been
absolutely outstanding in the first
quarter and here he is on the move
catching it with momentum to the cup to
score again
here is luca once again against the
zebox just absolutely torturing him
sets up people as we talked about in the
second segment of our broadcast tonight
and then there are nights
when he is just a splendid score and
tonight is one of those nights the luke
of magic
is showing out in quarter number one
i'm talking about assists who could say
the heck with an assist
isaiah heartstein is at the scores table
ready to come into the game
for the clippers now luke bernard no
foul was called he had his hands all
over him and still didn't keep him out
of the pain as lucas scores on the
floater inside
they stay close despite the fact that
they've had a front row seat for the
luca show
oh my
oh hi
three-pointer number six
they're calling me when a guy starts
launching it from the logo
a lot of people are watching trust and
believe in the post-game interview with
us he was mad that he missed the ninth
one and it is luca and he puts the
defense in a world of hurt again
oh look at that smile
is 29 by dirk nowitzki and 28 is the
number right now for luca with a minute
21 to go what will the clippers do
they're chasing it with zubots give back
to him there it is and there it is seven
threes made in the first quarter he'll
offer the drive to the basket and flips
it in 30 points now